so i'd imagine for you as for like a lot
of people who start questioning wokeness
you probably said something
small like hey i kind of don't agree
with you on the white people thing and
then they immediately started shoving
you as hard as they could out yep that's
exactly what happened i had so i'll tell
a quick little story i was working on a
project called the groveland iv back in
florida and it was about these four
black men had been wrongfully accused of
sexual assault and there was a
documentary that we were showing and i
was trying to get all these college and
high school kids to come and say you
know this is america this is what they
do to black people they shove them
through the criminal justice system even
when they dove nothing and in the
background brett kavanaugh gets accused
of sexual assault and that whole
firestorm starts happening and i'm
working on this project watching brett
kavanaugh just completely break down on
camera and i brought it to my boss and i
said you know why are we treating these
two situations differently why is he
completely just getting obliterated by
the media and by the work that we're
doing here yet when these four black men
get wrongfully accused we're giving them
all the grace in the world and he said
well he's a white man and i don't care
and he clearly is the frat boy type so
he did it and he should hang wow yeah
just
when i tell you the most dramatic
rhetoric you could possibly hear i was
hearing day in and day out i don't know
how i didn't leave sooner but eventually
it was just you can't stand it i kind of
feel like the left hates mixed race
people like woke people
like their their perspective is
i've experienced this personally where
they're like we should have
segregated spaces right the poc and the
non-poc and then you know if you walk up
to them and you're like what if i'm both
they're like get out because then you're
still white and and your story what i'm
imagining is like you've got white
family him saying he's white i don't
care let him hang it's like yo you
realize like when people say it's up to
me i'm like imagining my family i'm like
i don't like that right like you're
talking about my family too which was
interesting because i had conservative
people in my family who are sort of like
the fox news conservatives watching that
all the time and then i had my mom who
was totally on board of you know f white
people and i'm i just happen to be a
white ally but also i'm part of the
problem so my brain was just going crazy
all throughout my childhood did you feel
like she owed you an explanation did it
like hurt your sense of identity
you know i i just have conversations
with her now and say you know in the
future maybe we don't do this to
children maybe we don't teach them that
they're victims from like the age of
eight years old and and you know tell
them that there's some boogeyman out to
get them but he's invisible uh and see
how that goes and how did other people
in your community react when you were
like i don't know that i
totally get behind all these beliefs
anymore i was completely just ousted
from the organization gone left never
talked to again and of course later i
about a year or so later i started
making videos and and those sort of blew
up and
just people were pissed one story i talk
about every so often is that during
occupy wall street there was this dude
i was a white dude a black dude
and uh black dude was like i'm gonna run
across the street to go to the bathroom
and the white dude they were friends he
was like oh hey would you grab me a
cheeseburger when you're over there and
the black dude went off and he was like
excuse me and he was and he was like oh
can you grab me a cheeseburger when
you're over there i'll give you money
and the black dude just went off on him
started yelling at him and then i asked
him later what happened and then he he
said you see how racist that was and
then i was like he asked you to get him
a cheeseburger he's like yeah like a
miss boy like going to get him food or
something and i was like dude my friends
asked me to grab him stuff from the
store all the time
yeah there's afraid you fly i'll buy
that's what we do
what i think happened there was that
this dude internalizes the racism and
sees everything through her lens of
their you're being racist towards me so
something as simple as my friend asked
me to grab him food because i was
already going that way
turns into a racist attack on him yeah
one i think white gill is something that
people are introduced to at a really
young age i saw a friend over the
weekend and she's moved to new city and
she told me that she specifically picked
her yoga studio because it was in the
historically black neighborhood and she
liked that it was owned by women of
color and if that's your preference
totally cool and then she said i also
think it's really important that they
offer classes uh for free to black
people only and i think it's better
because i should be paying for it it's
okay if i have to pay and other people
don't and i was like you're describing
discrimination you know that right but
you know what am i supposed to say to
someone who feels feels like this is
part of her moral duty to the world
like you're saying kind of approach it
calmly this is what i think
people who agree with us need to
understand
there's no mistake they're racist
they they define racist in a different
way but who cares the way they look i'm
not trying to win an argument with them
over what words mean to me
my basis for racism is that they want
racial discrimination that they believe
certain races are inherently one way or
another or something like that
whereas i'm kind of like you know if i
went to a restaurant and they they had
signs about like only serving white
people or somebody said to me that they
that that they liked a restaurant
because it catered to white people and
offered free food to white people i'd be
like that's kind of messed up i don't
like that and if they did the same thing
for mexicans or black people i'd be like
that's not okay i don't like that that's
kind of lame
and
the woke
they want the segregation yeah like
it's fascinating when i talk to people
and tell them about how dearborn
michigan had the you did you see this
one the poc and the non-poc digital
events they did i've seen a lot of
places doing this tons of this stuff and
they're like it's a good thing and i'm
like it's a bad thing i'm like well if
you don't like it you're racist and i'm
like dude i don't care what word you use
i don't like what you're doing and i'm
just going to stay away from you and
that's the smart thing to do i mean you
know it vermex candy who we all know and
dislike talks about you know the way to
fix past discrimination is present
discrimination and how that lands with
anybody i just don't understand and i
think a quick thought exercise that
anybody can do is to sort of look at
these headlines and what these will
people are doing and swap out people of
color or black or hispanic for for any
other race and and see how you feel
about it see if it's truly racist and it
always is yeah it always is yeah it's
crazy i think part of it is people feel
like they are
um
they are doing the right thing by making
things by overcompensating you know by
saying like oh well we'll we'll pay more
now because at the time you were wronged
and i think we forget that we can
acknowledge that past wrongs were
committed without needing to you know
push a bunch of other people down in
order to make this unstable system we're
trying to build up on it doesn't make
any sense isn't it funny though how
there's an overlap between these people
they're the same people who support war
with ukraine they're the same people who
think everybody should bend the knee to
vaccine mandates like what's what's up
with that i think it's because you know
i was thinking about
that these i saw these memes about how
the christian right were mean and they
hated people and i'm like yeah that's
not been my experience you know for the
most part but i wonder because because i
know that they exist i i wonder if what
what it really is is that they're a
group of people
that or i should say a certain amount of
people tend to be
zealous
and
mob like
they don't actually believe anything
they just do whatever the dominant
social group says and they adhere to it
with with force and aggression and at
one point when the when when this
country was dominated by christians
those people claimed to be christians
gave a bad name now that the country is
moving toward secularism these people
are now the same people they've always
been but now just along with the woke
giving them a bad name and making them
look like garbage but the problem is
they're the prominent ones that are
pushing this stuff
obviously there's like regular people
who are like on the left i think racism
is bad but the dominant voices have all
become these like despicable weird
authoritarians and i think they make it
so um such a gray area where it's like
well your instincts on what is racism
and what feels wrong to you is wrong you
don't have a true understanding of this
because you don't have this knowledge
and context that we especially in the
realm of academia
say you must understand and go through
to really get yeah and i think another
underlying factor with why they do
things like the vaccine mandates and
jumping into war with ukraine when i was
working for the left there was this
constant idea of radical compassion so
you identify a problem you identify what
you think would be the compassionate
thing to do and you do that to the most
radical extent that you possibly can
which means hopping into war with russia
which means mandating vaccines for
everybody if you're if you want people
to be able to come into the united
states and immigrate here we need open
borders everything is always the most
radical form of policy they can think of
you know radical compassion doesn't work
in my opinion i tried it in 2006 on
internet videos i was like what would
jesus do with this technology he'd
connect with everyone he could and you
know spread the gospel listen to them
connect with their eyes and i was doing
it and it became so exhausting and a lot
of very weak people would would connect
with me and i was like i'm not turning
anyone away i'll talk to anybody and so
it broke me like the the the people that
were busted up psychologically were
infecting my mind with busted up
psychology and i was becoming busted up
and i realized it's not sustainable this
radical you you need to let people fix
themselves you need to maybe create an
environment where it's easier for them
some people can't be fixed but that's up
to that people i cannot fix them i can
only give them an opportunity to fix
themselves it's coddling it's what's
happening right now and that's what i
recognized a lot when talking about
being biracial in america so much as
what do we need to do for you what's
hard for you how can you get into school
how can you get a job and you can switch
out the race thing for for gender or
sexuality but that's constantly the
underlying factor is how can i be a
savior towards ex community it's funny
that i i think
there are different conspiracy theorists
factions
that
all will blame one group of people for
their problems
so like you've got uh the groups that
you know will be like the globalists you
know you know the more alex jones
oriented conspiracy theory types not
referring to him specifically but
you've got people who hate jewish people
and blame them for all the problems
you've got the woke who blame white
people for other problems you've got
occupy wall street blames the one
percent for all their problems it's like
if you want to figure out where you fit
in which group do you hate the most
blame for all the problems and you found
your friends
to me it's creepy because obviously this
this planet and society is extremely
nuanced and it's not so simple to say
there's one group that's causing all the
problems there aren't there's like
there's war there's countries there's
cultures there are ideologies within
countries and within races there's
different ideologies that are attacking
each other
but of course
the woke they've become the corporate
dominant and they blame white people for
their problems yeah our minds are so
simplistic i mean it's so weird that
we've reduced ourselves down to things
like race and gender which are just
things you can see to the human eye and
then we've just decided oh because i can
see it that must be the rule of thumb
here and there must be one ultimate
villain in every single case for every
single problem it's unbelievable how
simplistic our brains work i don't like
the black and white thing because we're
not black and white right that's very
obviously a wrong way to describe things
it's too simple it's not functioning
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there is a massive library
to check out so again go to timcast.com
or tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and we'll see you all there
you